hello everyone Perry here to tell you a
little bit about what I learned while
visiting the set of Captain Marvel in
the summer of 2018 while on the los
angeles-based set I got to participate
in round table interviews with the cast
directors Anna Boden and Ryan flack also
with executive producer Jonathan
Schwartz you can read a number of those
conversations in full on collider.com
but right now it's time to highlight
some of the most important things to
know about Captain Marvel that I learned
while visiting the set you're not around
it's hard to explain first up here the
key story details courtesy of Schwartz
the movie starts with the Captain Marvel
character already in outer space already
having superpowers and already fighting
on the side of the Kree in the
kree-skrull war
she doesn't remember her human pass and
has been inducted into the creat army
and becomes a member of the elite
special forces like team star force
Schwartz continued very quickly along
this journey they get dispatched on a
mission to an alien planet to fight the
scrolls and over the course of that
mission brie Larson's character gets
captured by the scrolls ultimately
Captain Marvel winds up on earth
crashing through the roof of a
Blockbuster video store and that's when
we get a younger two wide version of
agent fury and the two of them together
kind of have to stop the scroll plot on
earth and at the same time it gets to
the root of Carole's past all of Captain
Marvel's powers will be on display in
this movie Schwartz told us that by the
end of this movie we'll have seen the
full run of powers out of carroll he
highlighted flight strength and photon
blasts and also noted I think part of
what made us excited about the character
was that she was such a powerful
character in the comic books and one of
the most if not the most powerful
characters in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and seeing all that brought to
bear is one of the big pleasures of the
movie Captain Marvel is Carole's movie
but at times it's a Carol Nick Fury
two-hander Schwartz noted that there's a
Nick Fury origin story in there a key
part of that Argent story for fury is
the fact that at this time he was
feeling obsolete schwartz explained or
meeting Nick Fury at a very interesting
time in his life it's kind of the
mid-90s the Cold War is
over the war on terror hasn't begun yet
it's a little bit of a slow period for
worldwide espionage and I think fury is
kind of wondering what his place in the
world is in a world where he feels maybe
a little obsolete and then aliens come
down from outer space the movie will
include the Kree supreme intelligence
during our interview with Jude Law
someone asked him about what drives his
character and here's what he said he has
a very particular relationship and any
of you who know a lot about the kree's
there's a sort of divine element called
the supreme intelligence and that comes
to play in this and each of the Star
Force indeed each of the Kree Warriors
has a particular relationship with the
supreme intelligence and my character
has a very particular relationship with
supreme intelligence which becomes
revealed and is quite complex and
ultimately very revealing of what it is
that motivates now this one is for those
of you wondering if the Secret Invasion
storyline is part of the movie in that
comic book crossover the shape-shifting
Scrolls invade Earth by replacing
certain Marvel heroes with imposters
here's what Schwartz said when asked of
that storyline factors into Captain
Marvel yes we talked about Secret
Invasion I wouldn't go into this movie
saying which one of these superheroes is
a Skrull because Carroll is more or less
the first superhero to show up on earth
but are we planting seeds for future
movies always next up Hydra is lurking
when asked about hydras involvement
Schwartz teased I wouldn't go into this
movie expecting a bit of Hydra plot I
think because the scrolls kind of get to
be their own thing but if you remember
your Marvel history they're definitely
there now me Carole's best friend Maria
Rambo here's how the shona Lynch
described her character she is a fighter
pilot very strong very bold very in
control of herself I'd say in high
demand for the industry that she's in
the to share a deeply loving
relationship and because of that
Carole's disappearance is devastating
for Maria Lynch told us she had to go
through a lot of grief when Carole
disappeared and then suddenly she's back
and she has to kind of reverse that
grief and make it work for this picking
up of a friendship which is kind of
strange but ends up really beautifully
is there a future in the MCU for Monica
Rambeau Monica of course is Maria's
daughter and also somewhat of a nice to
Carole in the comics
ultimately Monica grows up to assume the
Captain Marvel title and joined the
Avenger so of course the big question
becomes will captain Marvel's set Monica
Rambeau up for future MCU appearances
here's how shorts responded to that one
I hope there's more story to tell with
Monica certainly the movie leaves it
open for that stuff you also might be
wondering what about things we know
happened in the MCU in the 90s for
example Ulysses Claus stole the
vibranium and there's also the death of
Howard Stark when those specific events
were brought up Schwartz told us it's
all happening it's all happening in the
background part of what we liked about
the 90s like I said was kind of giving
Carol her own turf there are a lot of
setups and there are a lot of
connections to other things happening in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe but I
think what's most important is giving
Carol space for her own adventure so
there it is guys some things to know
about Captain Marvel but we're only
scratching the surface of the
information I learned on set right here
so if you'd like to read even more about
Captain Marvel before the film's March
8th release head on over to Collider
calm
you